Quest'inverno mi contatta a Ted
e mi chiede di essere a Cortina
quest'estate mi sono chiesto mi sareste
chiesti sicuramente Cosa ci fa un
professore ordinario di chirurgia
plastica direttore di una clinica di
chirurgia plastica ricostruttiva
rigenerativa ed estetica di un virtuoso
ospedale Veneto
vorrei come ha fatto pipilab farvi fare
un esercizio e lo capirete guardiamoci
alle spalle guardiamo la bellezza delle
tonalità del grigio
e del marrone delle Cinque Torri adesso
con lo sguardo scendete alla meraviglia
delle tonalità del Verde che vediamo tra
i 2000 e i 3000 metri e poi sempre con
lo sguardo guardiamo il cielo che lì è
azzurro e qui è circondato da delle
nuvole che ricordano quelli di Turner
Per poi far cadere il vostro sguardo nel
bollone rosso di Ted Che cosa c'è tra
questi quattro colori
a parte l'azzurro quello che Io indosso
c'è armonia e quindi la bellezza che
stiamo cogliendo in questo momento è
l'armonia E allora quando ero giovane
quando Dovevo scegliere quale sarebbe
stata la mia specializzazione ero molto
attratto dal concetto di scegliere una
strada che mi ponesse continuamente di
fronte a nuovi limiti per crescere e per
capire che forse non c'è limite se
vogliamo recuperare qualcosa
in armonia che è la forma umana Ma la
forma umana che è contenuta nella pelle
Il contenitore e che è costituita da
muscoli da ossa da nervi da vasi da
tessuto cerebrale
è una forma che purtroppo può non essere
presente in armonia alla nascita pensate
la soddisfazione con la quale mettiamo
nelle mani di una mamma africana a nord
Hospital la cortina del Kenya perché
lavoriamo a 2800 metri quando
restituiamo un bambino nato con una
labio palatoschisi un bambino aperto la
mamma lo riceve nelle sue braccia
chiuso che può sorridere ovviamente lo
seguiremo per la cicatrizzazione ho
immaginate la bellezza di un momento in
cui una giovane donna purtroppo è così
entra in una sala operatoria perché
l'incluso come spesso lo chiamano ha
deciso di distruggere la sua mammella in
quel momento Nel momento in cui lo
allontaniamo dal corpo perché è
pericoloso restituiamo immediatamente
una forma Vogliamo assolutamente far
uscire la giovane ragazza sorridente
dalla sala operatoria con una mammella
ricostruita come
prendendoci a modello la mammella
controlaterale perché l'armonia è anche
simmetria abbiamo due occhi abbiamo due
mani abbiamo due gambe e quindi il
nostro corpo richiede nel momento in cui
recuperiamo la forma
armonia e simmetria Questa non è
bellezza Questa è la vera bellezza e
quindi progressivamente ho capito che
forse La Branca che avevo scelto era
quella più vicina al mio desiderio di
andare oltre i limiti ma sono un uomo
fortunato perché la chirurgia plastica
che passa attraverso la cicatrizzazione
che cerca di ordinare la cicatrizzazione
nel momento in cui interviene immaginate
Niki Lauda il suo grave incidente
d'austione che l'ha portato per tutta la
vita a sottoporsi a interventi che
modificassero l'armonia del suo volto
eravamo in tempi in cui la chirurgia
plastica
modificava la cicatrizzazione Oggi
invece cosa abbiamo nelle nostre mani la
chirurgia rigenerativa che è sicuramente
la nuova era e rigenerare Che cosa
significa cercare di restituire ad un
corpo quello che quel corpo ha perduto
nelle stesse forme non ci siamo ancora
per cui nel momento in cui decidiamo di
ricostruire questa mammella dobbiamo
ricorrere a una protesi di avanzatissima
tecnologia ma oggi iniettiamo del
tessuto adiposo ricco di cellule
staminali e queste cellule staminali
hanno il potere di trasformarsi nel
nostro corpo nelle cellule del sito dove
le iniettiamo il cosiddetto homing E
quindi cosa Facciamo come uno scultore
iniettiamo il grasso intorno a questa
mammella per dare un'idea di
rigenerazione una vera rigenerazione non
ci siamo ancora cosa ci manca ci manca
il fatto di poter sostituire anche
quella ghiandola malata con una protesi
che le tecnologie oggi ci danno Ma che
noi stiamo cercando di riprodurre in
laboratorio sono sicuro e mi auguro che
prima
la cosiddetta quiescenza riceverò dai
laboratori dai grandi laboratori di
ricerca di Padova l'organoide mammella e
allora saremo Davvero Nella
rigenerazione
l'altra forma che spesso la chirurgia
plastica cerca di dare è la cosiddetta
forma dopo il grave trauma vi ricordate
Nannini Nannini ebbe un incidente
Incredibile in cui fu amputato il suo
avambraccio immediatamente fu accolto in
un ospedale Toscano dove l'equipe di
ortopedia di chirurgia plastica
hanno riconnesso i suoi vasi le sue
arterie i suoi nervi e la mano è stata
rianimata ma spesso questo può non
succedere per svariate ragioni e perché
la chirurgia ha delle regole
fisiologiche per cui ci può essere la
complicanza ma la chirurgia plastica non
ha limiti Non si ferma e che cosa fa
oggi cerchiamo di stoppare il moncone
spostando un muscolo da un'altra parte
del corpo che sarà un lettore
intelligente
degli input che manda il nostro cervello
a questo muscolo che oggi finalmente
connettiamo con la mano bionica Padovana
una mano a 32 movimenti il nostro
cervello attraverso questo muscolo
trasmette il movimento alla mano non è
bellezza Questa è questa la bellezza che
questa chirurgia plastica rigenerativa
ricostruttiva oggi segue e segue anche
la possibilità di ridare luce ad uno
sguardo ad uno sguardo che in qualche
modo è annebbiato dal fatto che i nostri
tessuti
invecchiano i nostri tessuti cadono e
quindi il nostro sguardo Diventa quello
di Mafalda con gli occhietti all'ingiù
possiamo ridare luce come possiamo
ridare luce ad un sorriso
capirete che vi sto parlando della
chirurgia estetica e quindi
Oggi mi sento veramente
Combattente senza limite verso la
possibilità di dare bellezza a forme
perdute di dare bellezza come sintonia
tra la bellezza dell'animo e la bellezza
del corpo ma attenzione il corpo è
costituito da masse anatomiche che hanno
le loro regole e quindi dobbiamo essere
assolutamente
nel rapporto che si crea con chi ci
Cerca assolutamente
realistici su quelle che sono le
possibilità che il nostro corpo può
raggiungere in termini di simmetria e di
bellezza vi porto immediatamente un
esempio di quali sono le regole quando
dobbiamo Siamo di fronte ad una delle
cose più belle che ha il corpo umano
femminile che è la mammella Questa può
non esserci
può essere piccola può essere mal
formata può essere enorme o può essere
malata che cosa ci ispira nella
ricostruzione il triangolo vitruviano
dell'uomo di Leonardo e adesso vi faccio
fare un esercizio a tutte voi o lo
farete stasera Qual è il triangolo
ideale del seno femminile è un triangolo
con tre lati di 20 cm ciascuno quindi
nel momento in cui questi tre lati non
sono perfettamente uguali sappiate che
ci ispiriamo a questi principi
geometrici quindi ci ispiriamo a
concetti che la storia dell'arte ha
assolutamente proposto e imposto
nell'uomo leonardesco Quindi voglio
concludere dicendo che oggi mi sento
felice mi sento felice perché abbraccia
loro specialità che cerco di trasmettere
ai miei specializzandi che forse
apparentemente non ha limiti che non
deve portare ai limiti della bruttezza
che invece spesso vediamo e che non
vorrei che fosse più chiamata chirurgia
plastica la chirurgia plastica è
un'altra cosa ed è questo che ci sta
spingendo oltre i limiti ben consapevoli
che il nostro corpo può essere un limite
Grazie
[Applauso]